What do you mean there were no big sweep? What the [__]
is this guy saying? He's just lying. He just looks at the camera
and lies.
Does Ben Shapiro regret his vote for Donald Trump? If the president
is a plumber, is he going to fix my toilet or is he not going
to fix my toilet? What about the fact that when Trump pulls his
hand out of the fire, he often pulls out lots of cash with it?
I am here with Ben Shapiro. Ben, thanks for joining me on on
the podcast. You and I last spoke a little over a year ago. It
was a year a half ago before Trump's election
when our friend Barry Weiss had us debate I think the week before
the election. You know you're in the wrong room, okay? Talk about
our friend Barry Weiss. Our close, personal, you know, our mutual,
our bestie
Barry Weiss.
In a bad room. And a couple of things you said there have not
aged particularly well. I just want to do a postmortem on that.
>> were going to start here, so sure, go for it, say. >> Yeah.
I mean, I guess this is not a matter of I told you so, but I
actually just want to I want to understand how you're viewing
this. >> but it's okay. Go for it. You're entitled. I'll
I'll The truth is I don't I knew I was right at the time, so
there's very little satisfaction in in being discovered to be
right now. But I mean, two two small things that can kind of
give you a some kind of landmarks for the conversation. One is
that you thought
Trump's claim that he was going to tariff people extravagantly
was all bluster and we wouldn't see any of that. And needless
to say, he has tariffed nearly every member of our species. And
not just our species, we've tariffed islands that have just penguins
on them, apparently. Also, you thought Mike Pompeo would be the
Secretary of State and rather than that, he was properly defenestrated
and I think even his security detail was pulled even though he's
on an Iranian kill list. So,
>> those strike me as small things. The big thing Don't
worry, Ben. Israel's got Mike Pompeo, okay? Mike Pompeo's fine.
Israel's got him. He doesn't even He doesn't need the Secret
Service. Mossad is watching his back. Which is really what I'd
love you to respond to is that you were very confident that there
was there wasn't going to be much
that was fundamentally surprising about
So, Pompeo was either Secretary of State or I forget what he
was. Chief of Staff, Secretary of State, something in the Department
of Defense. He had some role in killing Soleimani. So, he's probably
on the same kill list as all the people who had a role in killing
Soleimani. second term and we could be we could be more or less
certain of that because we already lived through a first term.
And whereas my main argument was no, that the reason why you
can't draw that conclusion is that in the first term, there were
lots of normal people with normal political reputations to defend
serving as quote guardrails in the first administration and those
guardrails are now gone and therefore you you just have loyalists
and grifters and maniacs of one description or another who are
not going to protect Trump and the country from Trump's worst
impulses. That seems to me to be the crucial difference between
Did Ben disagree with
How did Ben even Ben saw who the cabinet picks were going to
be, right? Like it wasn't like we didn't know once the election
happened. It's not like we didn't know who the nominations were
going to be or the nominees were going to be, right?
This is the Richard Hanania thing. Richard Hanania thought, "Oh,
no, they're not going to put RFK in. They're not going to put
Tulsi Gabbard in. None of these people Pete Hegseth, no way."
And then all of those exact people were elected, were nominated
for those positions in the cabinet and then got
I can't believe Ben would think that. >> first and second
terms. I'm just I'm wondering what what has surprised you in
the last year and a half or so. So, I mean, we can start with
with kind of all of those things. So, I was surprised by the
decision to tariff the entire world, mainly because I thought
that that was a a pretty horrible idea and and pretty horrible
decision and I was extraordinarily outspoken and critical when
he did that as I continue to be. You know, I think that the only
mitigating factor there is that our Treasury Secretary Scott
Bessent is actually living on the real planet Earth and has been
able to Yeah, but Scott Bessent didn't want to do it. That's
the thing, Ben. They're not following Scott Bessent's plan. Scott
Bessent had a plan where he could start tariffing certain things
little by little to generate a little bit more income and then
Trump was like, "Oh, you could do that? Well, why can't we do
that on everything?" He was like, "Well, obviously that would
be terrible for everybody." And Trump's like, "I don't care,
do it. Global tariffs now." to mitigate the effects of some of
that and then of course I I thought very strongly the Supreme
Court would strike down so-called liberation day tariffs, which
which of course the Supreme Court did. So, my my main argument
with regard to President Trump for a while has been that the
guardrails would largely hold, that that it wasn't as though
there wouldn't be mistakes or or bad ideas that were put into
practice, but that the guardrails would hold and that his worst
mistakes would end up being mitigated by the pushback of reality,
which is I think sort of what happened with the tariffs is that
even the the the sort of most blustery comments about the tariffs
that that he made, many of those ended up being walked back,
holes ended up being punched through. Again, I'm not in favor
of what he did with the tariffs. I think they'd had some pretty
disastrous effects, particularly with regard to our relationship
with Canada. But I I will say that that what Let's put it this
way. What he put forward in a in a poster board that had nothing
to do with actual tariff rates and everything to do with actual
deficits that began I'm not sure why I should care that we have
a trade deficit with Ethiopia, but you know, everything that
was on that poster board ended up not being what is the reality
today. The tariff rates on that poster board are not reflective.
Yeah, but why are they not reflective?
It's like, dude, this is like
Basically, if you had a really in shape
I guess like lieutenant or something in the military who's holding
the nuclear football by Trump and the fact that he could outrun
Trump is your way to not like Trump is trying to nuke other countries
and this guy can just outrun Trump while pretending he doesn't
hear him and you're like, "See, guys, it's not even a problem.
It's not Dude, he he can easily outrun. Trump's like 80 and he's
fat. He'll never catch that guy." It's like, dude, your president
is trying to nuke another country. That's the problem. Stop pretending
that the fact that he's barely by the skin by the skin of your
or the the scruff of your chin, the with the hair the hairs on
your chinny chin chin. You're barely getting away with it. Barely.
The Supreme Court came in and canceled out the tariffs,
But like he tried it. He did it. It [__] up the economy.
It's actually the It may be the worst case scenario for
the average consumer, right? That they paid all these tariffs.
They they ate all of the price increases for the tariffs. They
paid all of them and then the refunds just went back to the
Um So, you get the decreased demand. Nobody buys and and the
people who do buy lose extra money and then the money just goes
back to the companies. It's like the worst thing for economic
growth. Like the worst of all worlds. You've accomplished the
worst of all worlds somehow. Thank >> today's tariff rate.
So, so put that out there. And again, that's not to say that
you were wrong and and I was right. I wasn't right. It is to
point out that that the the sort of outcome of everyone gets
tariffed at the rates he put out on liberation day, that that
is not what the outcome was. As far as Mike Pompeo, my my case
was that there would wasn't really specifically about Pompeo.
I sort of asked to speculate on who he might pick as Secretary
of State. Marco Rubio has done a pretty good facsimile of what
Mike Pompeo probably would have done as Secretary of State. So,
I'm not sure that that that counts as a major miss. As far as
the idea that he was staffing up with loyalists who are unlikely
to challenge him, I agree with you that he has staffed up with
people who are much more loyalists to him than they otherwise
would have been in in Trump number one. And I think the one of
the things that he has found to his surprise that many of those
loyalists have been This This happens to every single streamer.
I'm convinced you can't stream and not get like kyphosis of some
kind if you're on camera.
Like the the facial gains you get for just sticking your face
forward compared to like sitting back in a neutral posture, everybody
does it and then you see every streamer looks like this. They
just have like the Golem posture every single >> they otherwise
would have been in in Trump number one. And I think the one of
the things that he has found to his surprise that many of those
loyalists have not turned out to be particularly competent and
that he's shifting back toward a sort of more professional class
of people inside his own administration. And here I would I would
cite the substitution of the Secretary of Homeland Security.
Really, the the Kirstjen Nielsen was defenestrated in favor of
effectively of Tom Holman, who is a significantly more professional
figure and has served under both Democrats and Republicans. The
same thing I think is true of Pam Bondi, who I thought was a
bad pick, but has ended up being replaced by Todd Blanched, who
is significantly more professional. So, again, I think one of
the things about President Trump is Is Todd Blanched significantly
more professional than Pam
Is that actually I don't What What indicators do we have of that?
Why would I think that? >> he he definitely likes to stick
his hand in the fire and when he burns, he tends to pull his
hand out. That is again not to suggest that there were no risks
at all, but that the actual policy that has emerged from the
administration, the actual overall policy, is actually I think
not too wildly far from what I would have expected having charted
out term number one. I don't see a wild kind of swing into into
never-never land in in term two as opposed to what we saw in
term one. What about the fact that when Trump I RFK is your health
minister RFK not health minister cuz that's not what he's called.
He's the Secretary of H the
But essentially your health minister is RFK Jr. A guy who's like
openly skeptical of vaccines and a total
What do you mean there were no big sweep? What the [__]
is this guy saying? He's just lying. He just looks at the camera
and lies.
That's insane. And by the way, neither of these guys are going
to bring it up. Hey Ben, what's your opinion on Tulsi Gabbard?
What do you think of Do you think Tulsi Gabbard was good? You
think she was a good Was she Was she good director of national
intelligence or Office of the DNI? Trump pulls his hand out of
the fire, he often pulls out lots of cash with it. So, they take
the tariffs, right? I understand that you're you draw comfort
from the fact that the Supreme Court backstops some basic
with respect to the tariffs, but he nevertheless used this tariff
policy and
levers of American state power to
ring out an astonishing amount of money from our allies and enemies.
I mean, he slaps a 46% tariff on Vietnam.
Real quick, is by far worse than than Trump one?
I agree. The clown people who were in Trump 1 were in clown positions.
Right? All of the clowns were in clown positions where they couldn't
really affect things. He put the clowns in real positions this
time, okay? Like Pete Hegseth should never be involved in any
White House in any capacity. He's the the literal
He's the head of the DoD. The Department of War now.
Vietnam gets that reduced by green lighting a $1.5 billion resort
deal for the Trump family. By most estimates, the Trump family
has made somewhere between 1.4 and 4 billion dollars now grifting
with their cryptocurrency schemes and and other machinations.
None of this is getting walked back at least not like in prison,
but I will you ask it sorry. I did forget to say the one thing
that has shocked me is the level of familial corruption. I will
say that that that has surprised me. Um you know >> What
what amount of corruption
Like dude, Sam Harris should do do the honorable thing, Sam.
And ask him like realistically tribunals where we execute these
people based on their crimes. That would make sense here, right?
The level of looting of your own country is so baffling. It's
so insane
that like it's actually treasonous. It is flat-out treasonous.
I don't think there's another way to describe it. Like that is
the the rhetoric should be taken to the appropriate place. Everybody's
saying, "No, no, no, no, you have to walk the rhetoric back.
Things are too the temperature's too high." No. No, you don't
not describe these things accurately. You have to describe them
accurately. Like uh extrajudicial vigilante justice? Totally
disavow. No, do not do that. But these people need to be tried
somehow. I'm sorry, they do. >> would really matter. I
mean what what amount is so much that you'd have to say, "Okay,
I disavow this president."
Well, again, I'm not sure and I said this sort of last time we
talked as well. I'm not sure what it would mean to disavow because
politics is a sort of it's a sort of choice of of lesser of two
evils in terms of the politics. Yeah, okay. Now, I want every
single person to understand.
All right? If you are one of these people
who have run with the lesser of two evils thing, "Oh, you can't
take a principled position." None of you can remotely argue with
Ben Shapiro here. You all have to sit quietly with your hands
in your lap and just go, "Yeah, that's true. You see it as a
lesser of two evils, so I guess that's fine."
Like principally, well, principles you shouldn't have a principle.
You shouldn't have like a one issue, right? It should just be
the lesser of two
Isn't the argument just that Trump is worse? That is the argument
that should be the argument. But I'm telling you that most people
will tell you a lot of people will tell you that there isn't
like a principle you could put into place that should override
your overall calculus for the vote. You should never rule somebody
out based on them violating certain principles.
And Ben believes that. That's why Ben won't rule out Trump. Cuz
Ben doesn't really have that many principles, okay? Especially
well, outside of take care of Israel, which Trump has never gone
back on. The Ben doesn't have that many principles, so it's all
just calculus for him. And I'm saying there are certain things
politicians or anybody can do that should put you off of them.
And if you act otherwise, you end up being Ben
That's who you are.
Congratulations.
I'll see that I wish to see. So disavow Trump in favor of what?
I'm happy to disavow his his behavior with regard to World Liberty
Financial. I was I think the first conservatives talk about that
on Air with a Broke and I've I've talked about it consistently
ever since. That's it's sort of like saying, you know, what what
level of you know, corruption would have caused you to disavow
Biden when Biden was running against Trump. I mean the politics
is inherently a No, no, it is so so lesser of two evils calculation,
but I mean we we came from a world where had President Obama
received a cashmere sweater from some foreign power, it would
have been it would have hit the news cycle as some kind of scandal.
And now we're in a world where we're just you know, we're counting
billions and the billions don't seem to matter. I mean what what
would be so scandalous on this front where you'd have to say,
"All right, this is incompatible with American democracy and
America's role in the world." I mean again, this touches other
things. It touches foreign policy in my view. I mean if you ask
yourself had Maduro had the the wisdom to have purchased a billion
dollars worth of Trump's meme coin, do you think still think
he'd be running Venezuela? Um I mean I can't speak to that since
it didn't happen, but I I you know
I mean best guess, Ben. I do I do think that's like that is it's
just pay-to-play on a global on a the most insane scale that
there's ever been. I I will say that if he had done that and
then the president had suddenly come out in favor of Maduro,
I would have thought that that was insipid and insane. Right.
I mean I just I just think that there's such self-dealing and
such corruption and such a focus on Insipid and insane. Now,
back to how Democrats are trying to trans your kids. That would
be insipid and insane and I would say Trump that action from
Trump would be really bad,
Democrats are trying to trans the kids and they're trying to
make socialism a thing. They're trying to turn us into communists,
so really it's a lesser of two evils, guys. on on self here that
it's um it's hard to say that the the that Trump is is effectively
representing
anyone other than himself and his own I mean I think that when
when it comes to the interest that he's been pursuing in in crypto,
I think you're selling past the sale with me, Sam. I mean you're
not arguing with somebody who's arguing Yeah, so it's it's not
it's not just crypto. [clears throat]
this is the dude. Sam Harris is me arguing with people about
the the Saikouno thing right now. Sam Harris is me where it's
like people are like, "Oh, it's bad. What do you want me to say?"
And I'm like, "I want you to say this guy's like a total psychopath
who you would never have dealings with." That's what I want you
to say.
Let's get to that. How about you stop dancing and go like, "Well,
it's like that was a bad thing he did, but what what do you want
me to do?" Anything. Anything. Change your actions or perspective
with regards to this person in some way. touches everything.
Like so I mean I'm so you and I are going to talk we'll talk
about the war in Iran. I think you and I will probably view it
in very similar ways except for the fact that I think you probably
will draw a lot of comfort from Trump being in charge and doing
the things you think he should be doing, whereas I think he's
because he Dude, this has to be
How do you even have this conversation between these two people?
Cuz Sam Harris is like a rabid Zionist. Ben Shapiro is the most
rabid Zionist that exists on the internet that does commentary,
okay? I mean he's up there with Randy Fine and
uh Mark Levin, but he's actually been popular at some point.
He's actually been a popular commentator at some point, okay?
Now, Sam Harris needs to understand the only difference between
these two, well, not the only difference, but the primary difference
between these two is that support for Israel for Sam doesn't
mean like I'm willing to destroy America to support Israel. Ben
is totally willing to destroy America to support Israel.
And how do you have this conversation without bringing that up?
That that's obviously the breaking point between
Sam won't do it because it makes Israel look bad, but it's clearly
it's obviously the breaking point. So how do you even have the
conversation without bringing it up?
How do you how do you circumnavigate this? How do you even have
this conversation? Well, why do you support Trump now? Well,
Sam, you know exactly why he supports Trump, right?
That is the only reason he supports Trump. It's Israel. And he's
willing to let your country be destroyed
regardless of doesn't matter what Trump does. Doesn't matter
the corruption. It doesn't None of that will matter. It's only
about Israel.
And Sam's going to try to have this conversation about why he
regrets it or why he could regret it. Dude, as soon as the Iran
war was launched, Ben Ben would let Trump like if if Trump was
implicated all across the Epstein files actually and that became
public knowledge, Ben Shapiro would still be out here saying
like, "Well, you know, that's probably AI or something, guys.
I don't we don't know about this, okay? That's probably AI."
He'd be doing whatever he could to keep Trump in charge. In my
view, he believes almost nothing except in his own
just gratifying his own rapacious appetites that he's only accidentally
aligned with the interests of Israel, the interests of the West
against jihadism. And I think he's capable of selling out anything
you think he cares about in favor of of self- That's also accurate.
Oh, dude, never mind. Okay, Sam. Okay, Sam. You you know
Dude, that's crazy. So the difference between Ben Shapiro and
Sam Harris with that statement is
Sam Harris understands that he's protecting Israel now, but that
could just go away at any moment. The second some there's a higher
bidder at the door, he stops supporting Israel. So everything
put together, I don't support Trump. But Ben's like, "Well, he's
the only guy who will support Israel, so I still support him."
What a what an insane conversation. >> I mean I think he
I think he would cut a deal with Gulf states. I mean for just
take the fact that we're selling Nvidia trips chips to UAE even
though they do you know, military exercises with China and this
poses obvious security
That's just so that that was a World Liberty Financial deal,
right? That seems to cut against our interests. Well, so so here
here's sort of my question is is you are using his intent to
try to discern future pathways for his behavior. And the point
that I'm making is that if that were the case, you probably could
not have predicted many of the things that he has done on the
foreign policy front including his action in Iran based on just
pure self-interest. The only thing I can do I try not to do this
in in just generally is attribute motive to people. Is is Sam
not going to put it together that all of Trump's all of Trump's
actions are purely out of self-interest, purely out of like who's
bribing him? That's all he's done in Trump 2. And he went to
war with Iran?
What what are we to infer from this, Sam? If the best predictor
of Trump's actions are he will do beneficial things for the people
who paid him, what are we to infer from the fact that he went
to war with Iran? No, let's not think that far ahead. >> isn't
politics and actually prevent same conversations cuz you can
always attribute motive to somebody's political position. Somebody
may be in favor of instituting Obamacare because they believe
that it's going to save lives or somebody may be in favor of
Obamacare because they believe that it's going to end up with
money in their pocket. The bottom line is is the Obamacare policy
good or bad? So I try not to to do this too much. I try to do
this actually with Democrats and Republicans as well. Try not
to go to why are they doing this? Is it for nefarious purposes
or is it for good purposes? Because to me when it comes to politics,
the intent matters a lot less than the actual efficacy of the
policy or the or the through line of the policy. I think with
with President Trump even if you want to make the case that that
what he that what he does is driven by self-interest, I I say
that there's some complexity to self-interest in in President
Trump. I think first of all, you know, many people are driven
by
There's monetary self-interest. There's also the self-interest
of popularity, these the self-interest of notoriety, of attention,
and I think that you see many of those things emerge with President
Trump in in a wide variety of different ways, sometimes in Do
you think it was cut and dry that Israeli interests just flat
out paid the
Um like over the long term, absolutely.
Yes, abso-fucking-lutely over the long term, that is very true.
If that's just Lykens building the bridge tweet, he's not talking
about me there, Brian.
I I don't know like I do know that Jared Kushner building up
his entire hedge fund is based on Jared Kushner being involved
in the Abraham Accords and all of this, right? Adelson, yeah,
Miriam and Sheldon Adelson supporting his campaigns. There's
been a lot of payments for people who are very like who are extreme
Zionists, right? In America. There's been a lot of direct indirect
payments to him, campaign contributions, all this kind of stuff.
in conflict with with one another. But the only thing that I
can adjudicate at the end of the day is whether a policy or an
idea is good or bad, and am I getting more of that or less of
that from this president? And again, this this I think goes to
maybe unfortunately what what politics has become for for me
and for a lot of other people, which is the president is is not
a moral paragon. In my view, the president has not been a moral
paragon for a long time, and that Why? Why is the president not
a moral paragon? Why elect a leader who you're like, well, morally
he's a terrible human being. Why are you electing a
This is the highest power, highest
stakes job in human existence, in the history of humankind, president
of the United States. Why are you not electing somebody who you
think is a moral paragon? Like they need to at least have an
argument, right? Trump doesn't even have an argument. He actively
he actively vice signals.
He's not even attempting it. You need to pick good people to
be president of the United States. That's just fact That's just
factual. I'm almost positive if I went and looked through some
of those founding documents, that should be a part of the job
description, right? That this is a unique human being that is
like uniquely empathetic and understanding and wants to do the
best for the people. Like that has to be a part of being president.
I just I dude, it's so baffling to me that Ben would make this
this concession. It doesn't make any sense. It makes sense in
that Republicans couldn't win with the people who are actually
good.
It makes sense with that, but man, it's rough to hear that like,
oh, yeah, no, we're just going to pick terrible human beings.
Like Joe Biden, for all of his faults, was absolutely nowhere
near
Donald Trump. Like Joe Biden is by just far and away a better
human being. You heard Joe Biden when he sends that message to
his son. Like that's I would never hear I never heard anything
like that from Donald Trump. I've never once seen empathy like
I heard in that call. I'm talking about the voice message that
Joe Biden leaves for Hunter Biden when Hunter Biden either I
think he he'd been out on a bender or something had been going
wrong. I don't know if he quit a job. He's Joe calls his son
and just
no matter what happened, it's going to be okay. I love you. Come
back home. We'll figure it out, right? Is essentially what he
says. I've never heard that from Trump. I hear that from a lot
of politicians. I've I or I at least could believe that from
a lot of politicians. That doesn't exist with
And that might be the best indicator of
it's gone so wrong.
Is you're not you're not including that element at all. Nobody
cares about that element somehow. It's all about winning. That's
not President Trump only. I think that it's been a long time
since since we've looked to presidents as our moral paragons.
The president is a plumber. Is he going to fix my toilet or is
he not going to fix my toilet? And then I have to make a judgment
as to whether this president fixing my toilet is either effective
and if he's overcharging me and what the alternative would have
been for the plumber next door to fix
I'm sorry. Okay. Plumber, it's all a calculation. It's you know,
lesser evil. Somebody had to throw this in here. If she wasn't
my daughter, I'd totally bang her. Uh yeah, that is how he
Son, no matter what happened, it's going to be okay. I love you.
Well, I think if I if she wasn't my daughter, I'd be dating her.
my toilet, would he have been effective or would he have charged
me more or would he have left footprints on the floor? Okay,
let me take something like the reframing of January 6th as a
day of love, right? I mean this is a
I mean you you once said this was the most horrifying thing I've
seen in American politics in my lifetime. You called it inexcusable,
unjustifiable, awful on every level, disgusting on every level,
and just terrible. Now, but Trump has since pardoned everyone
involved. He called these people, you know, many of whom were
caught stabbing police officers in the face with flagpoles, great
patriots, and he he referred to them as hostages when they were
in prison. And now we have an official White House website that
reframes this day in the most Orwellian and delusional way, and
it advertises this reframing to the entire world as the view
of our country, the the view that our country officially has
of it. Again, that for me this is these are these these are moral
and political errors that are so catastrophic as to be disqualifying,
and yet you seem to have declined to pass any further judgment
on this. What's your What's your sense of that? Again, in in
what way? I see I see so much of this from
people around me as well.
And it's like, dude, I've seen where this goes, right? When you
absolutely refuse to ever
hold like a moral line, I've seen how that goes.
It's so bad. It's so so bad.
This is why I never I've never been somebody who's like, oh,
these stupid lefties who said Israel-Palestine was was like so
a hill to die on. Right? That they that you have to vote for
Kamala Harris, you have to vote Democrat no matter what. It's
like, no. No, you can pick a line. Cuz if you never pick a line,
then you end up with people like Trump.
God. Why do you keep coming back to this word dis- qualifying?
And the question is, disqualifying in what sense? Well, I just
I just want to say that that almost any any point else in office
would be better than this when I'm focusing on this particular
outcome, right? I mean no no other president would have done
this that we that we could have elected. I mean, I agree to a
certain extent, and the only reason I say to a certain extent
is because I think the reframing of of things that I consider
to be pretty dark moments in American history have been reframed
in the past, but not to that extent. I will agree. Uh the the
thing that I'm pointing out here is that when you say disqualifying,
the question is against whom? Okay, well, I'll just run I'll
run through a few of them. The toilet needs to be fixed. This
is You know, you don't have to you you're you're making again,
you you seem to you seem to you seem to want to make you seem
to want to make the case to me that Donald Trump is a bad man
who thinks bad things and has said bad things and therefore is
incumbent on me to support
The sad thing about this, and we could make this a whole segment
again,
if you read Ben Shapiro's memo, the first article that ever goes
up on the Daily Wire, it lays out why Trump why Ben Shapiro is
a Never Trumper. Like he made that decision the first Trump term.
And it reads like somebody who is principled, who has some idea
of what they want, and who says Trump's disqualified in every
single possible
And then that just then he founded the Daily Wire and everything
everything disappeared. Everything changed overnight. Kamala
Harris or to support Jon Ossoff or to support whomever else is
put up in place of President Trump. Number one, he's not eligible
for election again. Number two, in the last election cycle I
did not support him in the primaries. Number three, when it was
him against Joe Biden, then that was a binary choice. And when
it was him against Kamala Harris, it was a binary choice. And
again, the question with to me was, which one of these presidents
is going to be more likely to mirror my policy preferences, not
whether on a moral level I would have Donald Trump babysit my
children or maintain my There's more there's more that you could
be doing in your commentary to acknowledge the the the changing
political landscape, I think. So So for instance, I agree with
you. You could you only had a choice between Kamala Harris and
and Donald Trump a year and a half ago. Uh and you you might
still be able to defend I mean, though, you know, we disagreed
about it at the time obviously cuz we had that debate. You might
still be able to defend that choice in retrospect saying, given
what I knew then, uh it would seem to me to be the rational and
ethical choice to pick Trump. Again, yeah, I think January 6th
was a was the the bridge that once crossed completely obviated
that that decision, but Well, again, I mean, you you're see you
seem to imply that I have an obligation to regret my vote for
for President Trump. The path forward lies in no I mean, you
absolutely do. It's dude, it's
Just come. Just come. Just come.
Pretty sad to see supposedly learned people even totally incapable
of making moral decisions. Bleak outlook for the average person.
Eat turn them Zucks to save society.